[Music]
have you ever wondered why your mom and
dad laughed at spongebob even when that
scene wasn't really that funny it turns
out the cartoon world is full of
innuendos you just never understood as a
child we can't believe the jokes that
went on in Powerpuff Girls make sure you
never miss out on one of our videos
again by clicking that subscribe button
today we're talking about tens little
jokes in popular kids shows that only
adults will get hey Arnold
what hey Arnold had subtle jokes you
didn't understand as a child oh you know
it from grandpa's face to him saying he
lost quite a few brain cells since
Woodstock hey Arnold has more subtle
jokes than you can remember remember
Helga who named her fist the old Betsy
Helga who was a bossy bully that took
way too long to admit she actually had a
huge crush on Arnold and it turned out
it wasn't really a crush but she loved
him Helga has always been an expressive
character but it was her subtle jokes
that made adults laugh much harder than
children not only did Helga have a
shrine for Arnold and wrote surprisingly
good love poems for him but her dramatic
confessions sometimes took a slightly
less innocent root in a love letter to
Arnold who she called football head how
can express that she was so into him
that it made her girlhood tremble in Hey
Arnold the movie held him manages to
confess her love to him and corners him
which understandably makes Arnold
slightly confused after he says he feels
a bit dizzy and needs to lie down Helga
dramatically suggests she should lie
down with him do you see the subtle
jokes freakazoid freakazoid was another
show that had way too many jokes you
just didn't understand as a child if
you're not familiar with the show here's
a quick summary a 16 year old high
school student named Dexter Douglas got
some really impressive superpowers from
a computer bug when he accidentally
activated the secret key sequence he
became freakazoid a superhuman with
enhanced speed strength and intelligence
he can change back to a normal human by
saying freak out and freak in whenever
he's ready to fight enemies one of his
allies was sergeant Mike Cosgrove a
heavyset police officer who's always
kind although very monotone well
sergeant Mike Cosgrove actually gave a
statement that might have gone over your
head as a child but had you giggling as
an adult in an episode called tomb of
invisibo freakazoid asked cosgrove why
he never got married
Cosgrove hilariously replied that he
just likes his meat too much to give it
up for marriage after freakazoid had
informed him that he can still eat a lot
of meat when he's married Cosgrove
replied that he didn't know that do you
get the hint why do you think sergeant
cosgrove never got married
Rocko's Modern Life and who can forget
about the wacky show about a wallaby his
dog spunky and his friend filbert
Rocko's Modern Life was one of
Nickelodeon's very few shows back when
cartoons had no rules this might explain
the highly unusual scenarios you can
find in Rocko's Modern Life although the
show hasn't been on the air since 1996
it had many subtle jokes that went way
over your head as a child
do you ever the episode where Rocko
loses his job at the comic book store
and has to look for something else he
finds a very interesting ad in the
newspaper that says specialty phone
operator in the next clip it looks like
he actually got the job you can see him
speaking on the phone with a note next
to him that's explaining how he needs to
carry out his conversations his phone
job seemed to quickly end when he finds
his neighbor mrs. bighead on the other
line as a child you probably thought
Rocko had just another job and it was
nothing special right well fans of the
show had to do a few double takes to
discover that this was actually a very
subtle joke done by the creators of the
show
can you guess what Rocco's real job
actually was cow and chicken cow and
chicken is probably one of the oddest
cartoons ever shown on television
if you don't Romana had a chicken mama
had a cow dad was proud he didn't care
how that's the opening line of the show
and it makes complete sense cow and
chicken are apparently a sister and a
brother
human parents on the show their mom and
dad are basically shown as just legs
with human voices cow and chicken would
go on bizarre adventures around town
together and they add a somewhat
interesting enemy called the red guy who
always wanted to scam them in one way or
another but did you know that cow and
chicken had an episode that was banned
from ever being aired again after many
discovered the hidden meaning behind it
it was called Buffalo Girls and the
storyline was about biker girls who
would break into houses and munch on
carpets of course there's a hidden
innuendo in that episode that you'd
never understand as a child looking back
on the show now
did you realize why it was banned and
what the cartoon makers meant with
Buffalo girls munching on carpets The
Simpsons although the last cartoon on
this list really is the one with the
most subtle jokes that only adults will
get the Simpsons comes pretty close in
second The Simpsons is one of the most
popular kid shows on TV and since 2016
it is now officially the longest running
American sitcom as well as the
longest-running American animated
program but did you know that the
Simpsons had many subtle jokes only
adults were able to understand the
Simpsons raunchy humor is well known but
you might want to re-watch a few
episodes as an adult to truly understand
them in the episode called black widower
Krusty the Klown makes a suggestive joke
saying this guy walks into a bar and
takes out a tiny piano and a 12-inch
pianist oh no wait I can't tell that one
do you get it another suggestive episode
is called whacking day where Homer
participates in snake whacking which is
a tradition in Springfield in the
bedroom Homer asks Marge on some advice
how he should whack the snakes to which
Marge suggests he should first start
slow and then go faster and then there's
homers mr. plow jacket that Marge likes
to see on her husband subtle or not
what's your favorite Simpsons joke
Justice League want to hear a joke what
is the Flash's favorite part of a joke
the punchline Justice League was an
animated series that didn't have a long
run but that doesn't mean that it wasn't
awesome of course it was a part of a
much larger thing called DC Animated
universe
but Justice League in particular has an
amazing sense of humor which ranges from
normal jokes to well jokes that are just
a little bit more subtle and might go
over kids heads and it starts with the
very first episode of the series where
the flash likes a mint green haired
Justice League member named fire flash
is encouraged by shayera to go talk to
fire but then says yeah you'd probably
be wasting your time anyway
I hear she's you know she makes a long
pause and then says brazillian which is
where the character fire is originally
from flash laughs it off but subtle
jokes don't stop here an episode called
eclipsed flashbacks about his
superpowers and says that he's the
fastest man alive
- which Hawkgirl cheekily replies which
might explain why you can't get a date
how did this joke get past the people
who review kids episodes Johnny
Bravo enough about you let's talk about
me Johnny Bravo he's the ultimate alpha
male of all TV show cartoons
Johnny Bravo is a cartoon from 1997
which focuses on a buff overconfident
guy as the main character his main
mission is to ask a woman on a date of
course his egocentric personality gets
in the way and he's often unsuccessful
but as he is Johnny Bravo he very rarely
gives up even when he should he calls
women foxy mama and asked him to do the
monkey with him he thinks he's the
handsome man on the planet and he has no
reservations in asking if you want to
watch his chest move in slow motion
Johnny Bravo cartoons come with many and
we mean any jokes that probably went
over your head as a child in the very
first episode
Johnny Bravo is presented as an offer of
innocence to Athena and gets thrown into
a volcano a couple of seconds later he
immediately gets thrown out suggesting
he's not that innocent after all in
another episode the kids play pin the
tail on the donkey with Susie's cousin
Suzy says she doesn't remember the last
time she was blindfolded but remembers
the next second do you get these jokes
let us know in the comments below
Edie Edie and Eddy if you didn't think
Cowan chicken was a weird show Edie
he might take that spotlight the first
episode of edy at an eddy aired in 1999
the show was a huge hit and had an
audience of 31 million households both
children and adults enjoyed watching ed
ed and Eddy and it was possibly because
of many raunchy jokes the cartoon had
the show focused on three high school
kids who lived in a town called Peach
Creek Eddy is the leader of the pack and
the trio always tried to come up with
ways to make money of course they always
failed which made for a good cartoon
episode the story very rarely included
adults and the school time was also
limited which leaves plenty of time for
mischief
how about the time when Edie and Eddy
crawled under Eddy's bed and found
questionable magazines and plenty of
tissues or this bathroom which comes
with some suggestive notes like don't
touch yourself Eddy seemed to really
love the magazines how he complained he
had to clean his room he whispered
he was totally able to save his
magazines and after he cried that his
magazines are in the sewer and Edie said
the text will now be ruined
Eddy said he was more worried about the
pictures what else can you expect from a
cartoon show like Edie Edie and Eddy the
Powerpuff Girls oh wait wait wait
Powerpuff Girls had subtle jokes you
didn't understand to the kid oh yes the
show first aired in 1998 and it followed
the lives of three little girls with
superpowers Blossom Bubbles and
Buttercup they lived in a city called
Townsville and used their superpowers to
save the city from evil did you know
that buttercups original name was bud
but the creator changed it because
Blossom Bubbles and but their names
aren't even the same in countries around
the world
Italy calls them Lally Dalian Molly and
in Latin America they were chocolate
bubble and acorn but no matter what
their name was Powerpuff Girls were
funny and some of their jokes were a
little too subtle for a child to
understand remember when the Powerpuff
Girls made a new friend and introduced
her to the professor professor said he
bade the Powerpuff Girls in a lab by
accident and Robin replied that she was
an accident too
or the time when the Powerpuff girls
defeated the rowdy rough boys and
blossom added this comment whenever
their masculinity is threatened
they shrink in size or perhaps this
suggestive scene that no let's just move
on to the next cartoon can you guess
what the final cartoon on our list is
huh SpongeBob SquarePants
if you guessed SpongeBob SquarePants you
get a thousand points give this video a
thumbs up if you love spongebob did you
know that spongebob was actually created
by Steve Hillenburg a marine biologist
and a science teacher who also worked as
a fry cook at a seafood restaurant we
can definitely see where the inspiration
behind spongebob came from and the
reason why spongebob lives in a
pineapple is that Steve thought he'd
like the smell as it is very important
to sea animals
spongebob is popular with children as
well as adults and you wouldn't believe
how many subtle jokes you can find in
this show like the episode where
spongebob was making balloons for
Squidward but those balloons didn't seem
like they were regular balloons and why
is patrick shown without any clothes
while offering spongebob some see money
spongebob squarepants really has some
clever ways to make the adults laugh
like the time that spongebob finally
admitted he was ugly and proud and
shouted it so that everyone could hear
who them including Squidward who said is
that what he calls it rewatch spongebob
as an adult and we can guarantee it will
make you laugh even more what's your
favorite moment in a cartoon show let us
know in the comments below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe for more
entertaining videos check out 10 amazing
houses inspired by your favorite
cartoons see you next time
bye bye
you